yeah with one Muslim scholar in my
country yeah
laugh there's a such thing as a Muslim
scholar okay what's the question yeah he
called himself a scholar so but he was
always quoting the scriptures and
misinterpreting and perverting the
scriptures actually well give me give me
one or two of his objections and then
later on I'll let you call and answer
all of his objections but give me at
least perfect uh let's quickly deal with
this one Mark chapter 4 yes verse uh
um 12 to 14 no um 10 to
12 right Mark 410 to2 right yeah 10 to
12 yeah g I'm shocked a Muslim scholar
quotes Mark 41 to2 to show that Jesus
didn't want everyone to be saved exactly
you're
right
okay guys here's a question mark 4: 10-
12 Jesus says to those are on the
outside he speaks in Parable so that
hearing they may not perceive seeing
they may not understand lest they turn
and God would heal them but for you
those of you who are in the inside in
the Kingdom all things are explained to
you why is Jesus saying for The
Outsiders he's going to speak in
Parables because they don't he doesn't
want them to understand whereas the
disciples are part of the Kingdom he'll
explain The Parables is that because
Jesus had already predestined to destroy
them and didn't want to save them
or is there something else involved now
let me explain it to you are you ready
yeah go to Mark 3
22-30 Mark 3
22-3 yeah I got
it San I'm coming I'm gonna have to end
it right here after this one s Mark
through Mark 322 to30 read
this goad
yes start at Mark 3:22 again and let's
go all the way through Mark 3:22 to
30 22 and the scribes which came down
from Jerusalem said he has beob and by
the prince of the Devils casted he out
Devils did you guys see what they're
accusing Jesus pay attention to why
Jesus is speaking in Parables if you
don't get it you're not going to know
the answer they just accused Jesus of
casting out demons by bze the prince of
demons so they BL the Holy Spirit
insulted Jesus notice they insulted
Jesus saying these demons you're casting
out by the prince of demons so what does
Jesus
do and he called them unto him and said
unto them in Parables bam hold on Bam
Bam Joshua B you read too fast bam
Joshua okay notice when they set Jesus
cast out demons by belel the prince of
demons
what does Jesus do once they accuse him
of that what does he
do it gave them a parable is it a
coincidence this is the first time Jesus
speaks in Parables and it's only from
this time that he speaks in Parables why
do you think he started speaking in
Parables what did they kill Jesus what
did they call Jesus what did they accuse
Jesus of okay they said he was casting
out Devil's out by be so then why did he
now start speaking in Parables make the
connection because I want you to see
it yeah because
uh anyone help him why did Jesus start
speaking in Parables to these people
after this
point anybody
let's see who's going to get it yes Leo
no it's not because they W understand
they blasphemed the Holy Spirit they
committed the unpardonable sin it's over
for them no more grace and repentance
now judgment so that's why now he speaks
in Parables to
them you guys I mean come on Brethren my
brothers sisters in Christ I say this in
love you got to stop reading the Bible
on a surface level dig deep see see the
connection you blasphemed the holy
spirit that sin is never forgiven it's
over for you no more Grace no more
repentance now I speak in Parables
because I'm done with you I'm GNA hand
you over to what you deserve it's
over
H keep reading
now yeah so because they blasphemed
that's why he did that okay verse 24 now
yes
and and if a Kingdom be divided against
itself that Kingdom cannot
stand and if Satan rise up against
himself and be divided it cannot stand
but has an end no man can enter into a
strong man's house and spoil his Goods
except he will first bind a strong man
and then he will spoil his house 28
verily I say unto you all sins shall be
forgiven on the sons of men
and blasphemies wherewith whosoever they
shall blaspheme but he that shall blashe
against the Holy Ghost as has never
forgiveness but is in danger of Eternal
damnation because they said he has an
unclean spirit so why did Jesus start
speaking to Parables to these
Jews from that moment
on well you said because they blasphemed
so I said or this what you just
read you said I said it or is that what
you just read okay yeah that's what I
read of course you said it before also
yeah I guess you got to get it before I
read it yeah if you don't get it then
that scholar is going to Shish Kebab you
okay no no no I get it I get it now but
I said because you have said it earlier
two then it's also written in verse uh
28 and Joshua Joshua why are you yelling
at me you hurt my feelings why are you
yelling at me no no no I'm not
yelling why she yell at me again mommy
anyway you get the point
no I'm not yelling I get you I'm just
saying that's the way I speak so now if
I'm the Muslim and I asked you why is
Jesus speaking in Parables to The
Outsiders is it because he's already
predestin him to be damned or why why is
he speaking to them in
Parables yeah I would say that because
he had uh of course he has been
preaching to them and at this point they
don't believe him they don't accept him
they even accuse him of uh using the
spirit of the be to cast out devils and
they blashe against the holy spirit so
at this point to continue to speak to
them so by blasting the Holy Spirit what
does that show of them is there any hope
for them
now oh unfortunately there's no
forgiveness yeah okay so then why then
should Jesus why then should Jesus waste
his time explaining the kingdom when now
they've reached the point of blasphemy
which won't be forgiven and it's over
for
them so that's why he speaks to them in
Parables but then he'll explain it to
his followers and someone said well
don't we learn from Parables how you
going to learn from a parable if if you
don't understand it and there are many
parables there are many parables if
Jesus doesn't explain you won't
understand what it
means that's right right so did I answer
those two
questions yeah very well thank you so
much I appreciate that love you Joshua
of others but next time listen Lord
willing I'll contact you where you can
give me the rest of the questions we'll
answer by the grace of God but I want
you to do something with me what you do
is okay don't read too fast not too slow
and don't pause in between verses
because Timmy is coming off the wall and
don't yell at me cuz you're going to
make me cry even though I love you